ladies are robbed everybody is talking
about it however this is not a video
about ladies robbed this is a video
about something else entirely something
completely different the guilt trip so
the guilt trip is one of those planes
trains and automobiles type roadtrip
type movies we have one person who's
really annoying and naive but nice who
annoys the other person who's kind of
normal but kind of stuck-up that's this
movie however in this movies Barbra
Streisand and Seth Rogen playing mother
and son I will say this Barbra Streisand
was well cast in this movie she does her
job well is annoying overbearing mother
but she you know you wanna like her and
in a story which you know is like okay
they're gonna go on the road and they're
gonna bond and they're gonna have a
falling out and then they're gonna bond
again all right it's a mother-son
bonding movie so I know what it's about
I'm on board with this I want to like
the movie any son with a mom wants to
like a mother-son bonding movie however
this movie just annoyed the living [ __ ]
out of me and it bored me too and that's
a completely bad thing any two
sensations that a movie should not put
on people simultaneously is boredom and
annoyance but this movie does it like a
master I don't know who annoyed me more
Barbra Streisand or Seth Rogen and
Barbra Streisand it's really overbearing
and knowing mom you know she's always
pinching his cheeks and you're like
alright if that were me that would be
kind of infuriating also but ultimately
she's a nice lady so you do want to like
her and there's Seth Rogen who just
treats her like [ __ ] he's kind of a dick
to her it's okay to watch Robert Downey
jr. act like a [ __ ] to Zach
Galifianakis or Steve Martin act like an
[ __ ] to John Candy but then John
Candy has that one scene where he's all
like like I like me my wife likes me
you're like um the fast-forward this is
brutal
I mean it's good but it's just it's
rough but Seth Rogen just being a
sarcastic dick to his mom you're like
all right dude really what did she do to
you did she punch you when you were a
kid I mean why be an [ __ ] however
he's stressed out because he's the
super-smart guy who's made this cleaning
product that cleans better than anything
on the planet apparently and you can't
really sell it to people that's why
they're on a road trip there are well
more or less why they're on a road trip
go into these different meetings
pitching this product but then it does
that movie thing where this person that
has a master's degree in botany or
science or whatever the hell he has a
master's degree and he's so smart but
he's an idiot it just seems like that
cliche Hollywood thing where it's like
oh this person is smart because the
script says he's smart but his action
show that he's actually a dumbass me
more or less seth rogen is the same
thing in everything really only thing
that's different about his character is
the character description within the
script other than that he's Seth Rogen
who does Seth Rogen he quips and sarcasm
that's what he is in this movie the
scene that I actually liked in this
movie was the Steakhouse scene I
actually enjoyed that same but that's
one thing I can't make up for the other
90 minutes of me going
no I'm bored and annoyed that's bad
the Steakhouse scene was ultimately like
an episode of man vs. food in which case
I would rather watch the slob from man
vs. food just eat a lot more real and
maintain his status as a national
treasure in an American Hero having to
sit through another hour and 20 minutes
of crap and annoyance no that's not
worth it movie has a couple of times
very low okay that's really sweet I get
it I see it a solitary confinement it's
it's solitary it sucks it's not good if
someone smuggles you a couple pieces of
bread yeah you had those couple things
they're kind of brighten your day but in
the end it's still solitary confinement
and it's still terrible the baffling
amount of unoriginality in this movie
mixed with the annoying characters who
annoy each other annoy themselves and
annoy me just it made for a mix where
I'm like nope no I'm done I haven't
given one of these in a while so hey
let's let's just give it end of the year
kind of [ __ ] the guilt trip is [ __ ]
so what is a good mother-son bonding
type movie out there I can't think of
any off the top of my head but they have
to be out there otherwise this is a
really poor first attempt what's your
favorite whatever it is comment below
let me know and as always if you liked
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]